[Music]
what is up everybody good morning and
welcome thanks for joining us today
it's Monday Persia here joined by Richie
and man we've got a treat today actually
which also explains why we're starting
at 12 today but it's really awesome
because today we're actually gonna be
able to play some Ghost Recon breakpoint
snap those of you with you play know
that you guys are gonna be able to play
like tonight actually like it's
sometimes very very soon today if you if
you are you play member so if that's
something that you're interested in make
sure you hop on that otherwise it is
coming out I believe on Friday I think
so is the official like worldwide launch
day but yeah here we are what is going
on everybody thanks for joining us and
I'm just gonna jump right in
while we're talking it to you guys you
know but maybe later so all I've done so
far is I had just started this up and
then I did like the lightness and
brightness settings and I continued it
started playing cutscenes so I kind of
just like exited the game real quick so
I'm hoping it takes us back here's
hoping no big deal if not I did confirm
that this comes out on Friday
yes how's everyone doing a chat what up
y'all man hey rebel X hello my ghost
Jack's gamer in the chat says sup
was what's up gaming HQ we're looking
forward to this one anyone else oh yes
it did come back okay alright let's
check this up
welcome to Aurora the incubator of world
2.0 my name is Jace Callen we've been
expecting you
you've been invited here to innovate to
invent and to create but we're also
asking you to do the most important
thing with your lives that you can do
here away from the rest of the world we
will build the tools to leave the planet
into the future a completely sustainable
economy a blossoming environment safe
homes security for your family and a
community where innovation is celebrated
the generations that come after us may
forget all about us but they will thrive
because of the work we do here thank you
for joining
[Music]
Oh
there we go we've got our objective
hey everybody
sorry we wanted to give you time to
process this beginning intro here
without too much chatter for sure
my handle is Persia that is not my real
name
a lot of people think that actually
those eyes oh I like how it is that
totally blended in with like I thought
this was gonna be yeah that was smooth I
like it look nice well you guys know me
there we go you got the cool scars
everything there oh man tons of options
I notice a lot of games have been like
embracing all of the customization yeah
maybe beeping it up good autumn Nate's
games what up hi we are a little late
but yeah so we can get the code for yeah
it was for a good cause
yeah man that green is still nice so
we're gonna leave it on yeah so cool
hair like very badass there's no wrong
answer here I don't think the mohawk
Mohawk it's pretty legit part or the
slicked back one strand of hair edges I
think it's a pony on the back but I
can't rotate my character it's up rats
well we'll go with the ponytail what
alter that hair color Oh
Dexter would Oh what is uh thanks for
joining us today yeah happy one day by
those yes I kind of like the great kind
of like the great TV there wasn't oh wow
David have some burn marks that's
intense
I know that when will man up some Joker
a joker holy smokes
one side too I was kind of feeling that
Joker one actually you go for it you
can't we've been through some ish yeah
look at those eyes they have stories
start with this appearance oh wait
cannot be changed later oh we got commit
I'm cool I'm cool
they make you hold down the button
they're like very sure you can't Oh yep
confirm everybody she's young she just
died her hair gray for the aesthetic
there is a ponytail Oh nightmare fuel
right as someone flies
silly princess just popped in house
breakpoint so far he popped in at a good
time we're about to start
welcome oh okay you lived I'm upside
down you are your pod is running up
this is booking
we are not we're not co-opting we're
just running through a rough start
all they're armed
yup well that was a lot earlier when I
said my characters been through some ish
no yeah yeah we just assumed no she's
actually been through something you all
were here to see a chat what's up says
this looks intense as hell yes yeah we
haven't even we just started and it's
already like yikes for real
taken agender heal injury lb okay are
you playing on PC with an Xbox
controller yes yes no judge me stream no
no the keyboards way over here you can
anyway from there alright so I'm healing
myself
yessum mgs3 healing right there on the
spot because if you guys remember from
like the gameplay presentation and all
of that this does have some permadeath
things and like got a hugh yourself or
else you will bleed out and die
so yeah christopher we did create this
character you just missed it but uh
she's our badass main character here oh
sorry
runnings all the same but winning ATS
you go to first person which actually
kind of
all right so we gotta make our way over
there but they leave these curious so if
you're just tuning in we crash-landed
and were we have no answers or we're
just trying to figure out how to live
here just started thank you all for
joining us by the way this has like a
horror game feel right now so I'm like
pretty spooky eerie especially that
intro oh it's it's like sunlight alright
rb2 open the item will an artist select
an item to equip ah
I've been limited bandages that's good
that's nice okay got you you ready
patched yourself up as soon as we landed
Oh Oh bad dudes
oh yeah prone camel this is another
thing from the I can like scoop some
dirt on myself
it's wondering what that meant there you
go yeah but it comes off the second day
roll one around okay cool just before I
get too far into this I just want to see
there we go
I can change my button layout Jessica's
here Travis says so ready for modern
warfare okay yeah we appreciate that
comment - I am really ready actually
witness the beta controlling so do they
have a controller oh it's next to it
Johnny pay says you can actually change
the camera when aiming down sights to be
third-person but I think you enjoyed
appreciate the heads-up though it was
very nice
oh no presets it's kind of just like do
what you got to do you know what I'm
just gonna wrong the default you got it
it's fine it's fun no game is without
its learning curves
yeah we got some bad guy up here right
there
hey Roberto would have been tagged him
we are playing on PC actually we got the
controller but we're on PC currently it
looks really good yeah I only see but he
was I heard someone talking I don't know
maybe he was a radio oh man would you
attack first are you gonna sneak yeah
I'm like decisions decisions
this is why I'm too indecisive making
them like me to tag this guy too
how is this cool voice okay uh what
should we do Chad should we sneak on by
yeah should we take him out I actually
don't know what will happen if I take I
think there's some bad guys you always
got to wonder how hard you're gonna blow
your cover if you okay okay no just
these little foot soldiers it's early
too so it's like are they gonna try to
teach me a lesson
I sure do you just take him out Jay mark
definitely not being attention I mean I
feel pretty common I could smoke him oh
you know what oh wait I just sticking up
oh he took it off oh no all right so
obviously we're gonna smoke this guy
over here first cuz we got silence yeah
he's further away not paying attention
yeah there you go Nate's games do some
sneak attacks we got him
yella cleared him out sure looks like
chat this is in favor of sneaking I mean
this is pretty sneaky it was aggressive
yeah yeah but like I kind of like that
you don't have to press any buttons to
pick things up in something there I'll
see if they have like takes stealth
takedowns or something yeah if you get
close enough there should that be cool
there's extra paranoid are the
helicopter from the cutscene that we saw
go down yes how buggy is it we just
started where we're hopeful but it's
looking and playing well so far I think
Persia would say oh we did just start
them yeah true Bob Jones the only one
who's like going guns blazing great we
appreciate that
I think we're gonna we'll see it might
call for that later no way to go alright
so he did that's what we found out
during our investigation small follow
the smoke columns chad is saying our
picture-in-picture little box might be
in the way appreciate that yeah it's
gonna take once you want to walk around
while we do this real quick just so you
guys aren't like just stuck on a blank
screen Roberto says the beta was buggy
but fine how interesting
hopefully this is a little smoother yeah
I mean that's the point of betas right
right like let's see what's going on and
see what works and see what doesn't
whoa we got a new gun from this chest an
ASR mark one big-ass gun alright I moved
the camera looks like it's in a better
spot I think good go right
obtained new gear we did for sure no
problem
that box was just they wanted to be
opened oh I went to this long as I had a
little exclamation point it looks like
we've got some PvP I mean I don't know
many people are gonna be on right now
because we got some early access but
this is cool yeah this does come out
Friday for everybody
all right Lobby crime what happening I
hope your level of one yeah we're
starting off we're green heavy hitters
today you go alright ah
oh that's what you pressed huh yeah okay
then go away a little pop up there I
need this going him but not really
looking around I feel like I do I think
how quietly eight things I'm now they're
just longer map
[Music]
what oh yeah why they get the assault
rifle if you want I mean I think it had
a silencer it looked like it the barrel
was uh-huh well not in that picture yeah
see now it looks like it does so if you
want to roll with that it's up to you so
we're a silent it's on now oh man you
know I just want to but told you guys I
would try some stealth action so let's
see let's go around even though they're
not really in the direction pick up some
goods there we go to read their closet
yeah they got it they let this wide open
I can play like the old lady get some
intel on when early axis starts for
anyone if that's an option oh this guy's
already on to us he's kind of smart
actually the guys running his mouth
they're here for a reason man you landed
in the wrong spot the story just put you
here alright look for blood trails we
may have survivors yeah those [ __ ]
are dead
that's about us now yeah all right I
might have to go around this other way
here
however this looks very makeup on them
yeah you pinged um you know where
they're at it would just be so using
this oh oh nice vantage point there has
to be some sort of shakedown right
Howard goes so goes like like free mo oh
yeah yeah Glenn you're right we got our
our code from Ubisoft themselves like
this isn't early access for everybody so
we wanted to bring it to you early
playing all right
I'm assuming it gets all shady like this
to show that I am indeed hidden for sure
in stealth no I don't like that guy I
don't like I know you're like turn
around there you go I mean I feel like I
can take my cover
SiC role though look at you got ya was
there a prompt for a sneak attack I'd
even see some options for a second but
then they turned around sorry you took
care of them yeah it's all good is your
help okay he's at the bar on the
boundary oh that's lady stamina yeah
all right well those guys all good yeah
and believe I was just a little lady
like someone had been there a lot of
random bunkers out here for like they
don't know where I was yeah I am playing
on normal difficulty there was arcade
which was below this one are to take
down an enemy oh now they would soon as
you saw them this message should have
popped up oh there is we could it be
stealth in real life we'd be like I know
y'all day
fortunately our characters got it down
on lock she's quiet
yeah yeah okay maybe I'll just shoot one
oh why not have my it's not silent
enough apparently
I think it's cuz you didn't finish them
all I don't know oh that shot hurts huh
Oh it said that you are this dude huh
run for your life okay next time we'll
use the pistol how about you guys in
chat played the beta yeah I actually
didn't play the beta so many betas
recently that's true I get around to
this one myself you've got to be alive
here we go alright let's go don't cloud
one one this is Weaver come in over this
is Weaver come in over anything
well gods
Walker shower Weaver
I mean I was expecting that gonna sound
way more like boom Chris I'm using he's
the Punisher dangerous area enemy love
seats it's oriole oh yeah because that's
one thing about this game is the AI kind
of adapts you I guess so interesting ah
gotcha
I see no hat obviously it's not only it
yeah I don't think that what the hell
are you doing oh okay oh [ __ ] up there
all
I mean what's going something if I'm
just smoking them rainout yeah it did
look like the objective point it changes
like to the West but I don't know I take
these guys out if you want I'm sure you
do
I mean I mean sounds like a pretty good
idea you have a grenade oh you're so
right I don't
yeah oh yeah there it is
I got I don't have one gonna oh yeah
you got it oh man that doesn't go very
far
oh okay cancel that okay put that back
in the pocket let's go closer even
though our objective is over there
really I don't know I think it's because
they were like Red Skull and am user
harder to to oh wait wait wait another
one yeah Oh an another like that yikes
oh yeah oh she went in wait there's also
someone over here anything man I mean
you can if you just want to you know
wreak some havoc wait it says 150 does
that mean my gear score should be 150 or
is it theirs to kill I mean I should
have read the tutorial a little better I
guess that's right we're all learning
suppressor I'll turn it on
oh whoa whoa they can't hear me
self's y maja chad is like get closer
suppressor ah first they were sneaky
they're like yeah they're like no no
like we've seen how things go when
you're installed there we go okay I
think I'm gonna I'm pretty sure I'm
gonna die but you know what listen for
you Jeff yeah just go in and rowdy
Saddam because it's a whole damn army
you know what it seems like my uh Wow
cannot switch weapons and prone so
realistic really no wasn't doing over
here rolling around the alright I
actually think we could do this Wow pick
them off maybe mmm-hmm was that guy has
a very bad oh wait we know game we know
I know it's dangerous I can feel the
pressure but I want to be one with the
trees here very tactical yeah this is a
tactical shooter after all Bob Jones in
all caps
shoot them all oh we're going to don't
you worry quick reload I feel like
wherever there's a red bar like a red
spot is someone standing there that I
didn't see that could just be a guess
but well kill way to learn it you're far
away enough I think I can't I'm a part
of this rolling around that would be
rumors y'all need to go somewhere it's
time to die you guys it it's oh man I
think they'll chill out
I'm hoping lakhs what if they step on me
oh this is like COD floor I remember
that all right you know what it's all
good that's good yeah good first first
effort you know I really thought I hope
that wasn't like permadeath I'm never
gonna be able to flip I guess that might
happen
Oh Johnny tsunami says the guy on IGN
died instantly
also we took a little bit but I took a
phrase now honestly I wanted to see
because in most games you'll hide like
that and they just never ever see you
they'll stop being suspicious and they
go back to where they they were before
right now it's a little weird our feet
wet we're learning person you're doing
great right yeah I do think I'm not
supposed to fight these guys right now
and I'm just supposed to go the
objective but gosh it's just too
tempting yeah well you tested it out you
can you do you have this game you can do
whatever you want and what you can do
climbs alright I'm out I've already
tested my luck I took down like two
people it's fine we're gonna go the
objective for sure we've had our fun I
do think the 115 excellent means like
your gear score should be around here
before you decide to like yeah attack
I'm like on three gears go
what's the install size I think for PC
it was somewhere around like 41 gigs or
something like that cool alright so I'm
just gonna take out these oh hey there's
a lot less over there that's all good
they don't have the Red Skull good eye
though I barely even saw them i kind of
blend him in
huh huh was that noise your bald head oh
yeah look at that tree that's pretty
good
Wow I like these icons let's unlock our
first class you guys sharpshooter what
do we get
armor buster nice longer breath control
snipers oh yeah I might definitely go
with that one Oh cloak and yes look that
looks like you just you're running
gunner whatever this what else True Grit
gas grenade extra health recoil
reduction damage resistance these are
all good no what the hell Chet help
throwing drone medkit faster revived
carries bodies faster self revive hmm
tempting hmm there's so many good
choices
wait this isn't fair Evie says play on
extreme and no hub you crazy boy yeah
what do you guys think well which way
would you go I'm kind of between Panther
and sharpshooter
but assault is also cool cuz you get
bonuses and extra Hill those two in the
middle I think were my favorite the
other ones are like smart options but if
we're gonna go ham like this yeah we
might definitely need some extra help if
we're gonna go him yeah bonus stealth no
faster movements whoa oh wait hold up
suppressors don't reduce damage on
handguns and submachine guns that might
actually be pretty good that is cool
sure great for stream you know just cuz
you were very convincing with that
statement I think I might honestly I
need extra help I need it I need it
anther Panther of cool man guys stop
guys stop the decision-making is it
sound we did like a profile here here at
work where we just found out like how we
are as
negating himself like that and one of my
biggest like focal points of my
personality was I was indecisive so this
is not helping even though we were like
let's go check yet we're not reviewing
this right now we are just playing for
fun yeah we got a totally in for you
guys comes out Friday though yeah
all right it's between assault and
panther I would love some extra health
but actually I feel like faster
movements be it might be might be the
wave is that it and you disappear behind
the smokescreen which also might be good
I think this is looking like a winner
you know so the video sold me all right
here we go more votes for Pam to your
right Nate even myself okay so I have no
skill points but coming up we can either
what is this oh hold Miami where Anne
will pick up nice night vision deploy
your parachute oh I can jump off of
cliffs yeah oh yeah that's definitely
going first because I want 20% more XP
the chata same and they're all the way
alright Panther all the way we've made
the correct decision meow meow there we
go
Evie says be a sniper
we only have two guns man right now we
only found the handgun and this assault
rifle there you go oops doesn't matter
if they saw me no way I am fat okay here
a bullets okay good stuff
apparently take them all out oh that was
dope sick God roll that Dodger old uh my
old bones could only take so much
yeah you just fell from the helicopter
crash also you're rolling around Pink
Panther yes that song always has sounded
like a sneaking song you know smoke man
you are really no wait so I ask you uh
ha
kondeh car hello hello I hope I said
your name right welcome let's believe
you got spec ops in the area boy do you
know who I don't even know what's going
on oh look at Black Star the Black
Panther ranked Panther so read that
wrong there's got the skill up who else
who else wants a piece being crazy over
here being crazy I'm here to collect my
loot yeah we know gimme the loo huh and
you're closer to the helicopter I think
that was the next accidentally hitting
so we're gonna go through this class
upgrades oh I must have gotten your
point you did
oh I see I see very nice very nice
oh man this it's like how's the
ever-so-slight is delay all right we got
one skill point we already said we're
gonna boost our XP from the start you
can get all of them juicy here here
radio interference should just go on
with the story about so many gears yeah
it's um Glenn says if you click the
right stick wall aiming you can aim over
the other shoulder oh yes yes I really I
was actually wondering about that person
that's always one thing with them only
on too much ps4 when I see X I got
alright marisa acocella the radio from a
goes back this ghost still breathing or
run with the Red Queen give me a sitrep
understood go see down hmm well
hopefully no one was that oh right
bumper e to shift shoulder distinct
dream they can't see me just pull out
yeah krome were they gonna do stop the
train that'll take forever all right I
still had a skill points I want to make
sure I'm getting all the usage out of my
skill points here Andy asks is this the
full game oh no wait I don't JK it is
right we got the code the whole game is
sent to us a little early so yes Andy
this is the full game I started away
from the beginning
why is she injured oh yeah I was like I
need my interface back no you are faster
this is great see how fast my role is
cool as ever I love hanging out in
groups like this it's smart but you
wiped out my person when they don't got
skills I think I'm close enough for a
grenade that's what I thought too
all right I'm just gonna inch over as
you know Chris Riley says hey if you put
your weapon on semi and push it and pull
the trigger and hold will shoot one
round but you'll have your fixed oh wait
you have your fixed in that you'll have
it fixed in that direction and move
faster home a lot of little details but
you guys got to play the beta here well
that would do what I live right ahead is
gone that was so cool I'm Batman
straight up yeah you knock them all out
yeah man my throwing arm is pretty
trashed
upgrade some new knee pads
dang cuz you know you got to protect
your knees when your ghost Bob Jones
asked can you climb trees a fan no
because that would be Oh oh you kind of
party yeah no no there was some weird
stuff there though for a second wait
some cars they just left there by tiny
decisions I think I'll definitely blow
my come around this
sweet
I don't see anyone either
you're not drawing any attention oh yeah
nice top we're just cleaning them out
get through this and you got a school
and one stole their ride
and
[Music]
wait let me use my skill playing face
next chat no no we got to get you a hat
Persia for sure my scalp this cold you
wear backwards and look real cool
alright so we wanted to activate the
parachute next want to be able to do it
and Donna's those buildings Nate says
use the car with the minigun we got it
but we don't have a gunner man
not this time huh yeah
see some question marks on the map up
here but feel like I should be stealth
[Music]
chad is saying looking
we got that little objective point but
[Music]
good for now
whistles OH - flashing blade
but we're just gonna try yeah I can see
it whoa
[Music]
I'm just gonna get close enough smart so
scenic look at the mountains all right
I'm thinking we might be close enough
these two these guys to try the
community Oh perfect just hook it right
over what an eagle eye okay there you go
oh look at that oh nice Jason Statham
all right Adam that grenade was just uh
you know a present kondeh car yeah I
mean it it might be a little lacking on
the phone if you're watching us on your
phone but we're watching on a pretty big
monitor looks really good also got a
skill plane and I've also got a new gun
oh you could be a gunner but you need a
driver oh damn it
cool all right very tactical me past 12
pen we're getting somewhere now and then
another skill point all right do we Wow
to pick up more ammo and hold more ammo
or night vision it's kind of daytime so
I think we can do this one sure
oh snap we can seize now manage you'll
get another one soon he's got a knockout
more fools yes so take this ride time to
drive
Luzi now we have windows this is a big
chunk ajar
or time I see another car I'm like who
there oh yeah
oh yeah it is coming to games coming to
all consoles Friday we're playing on PC
currently yeah well except switch
unfortunately
we'll leave this here the shade so it
doesn't get too hot in there when we
come back it's been pretty quiet and now
you're right up here Chris Riley says
the street being speed is too slow I
mean I feel like in a game like this
they probably wants you to do less of
that and more I'm like the tactical
stuff do you feel it's too slow well
right now and if you're are you talking
yeah it has to be pretty slow sure yeah
it's probably more to push you to be
more tactically yeah that and like you
know it's think about other like csgo
and stuff like that they actually your
accuracy goes down tremendously when you
shrink a lot so maybe that's another
thing oh wait those are my squad this is
where you can breathe great job stop
right there
oh who are you I was invited who the
hell are you another one another we can
always turn around and go back down the
mountain things are a little tense
you know just watch how you handle that
weapon you don't allow shooting an arrow
on they look related know what's here a
while my long-lost sister gave great
heart get in
well you found a base but it's pretty
tense in here I know I found your sister
all right what's back here find the
survivors reach the other surviving
ghost mm-hmm
and here is where I can now join an
invite players oh this is where it opens
up that's cool
please use the helicopter oh that'd be
dope
we uh sure if we find once this place
wow I wasn't expecting it to be all it's
like a farmers market I want to live
here beautiful yeah wow so scenic are
you boys all right or what you're
looking at me like that for ya know the
only two left in our chalk no radio no
drones between the two of us we got two
rifles and eight mags locals got water
here some supplies he believes this
place man
My Mind's blown yeah they're friendly
more or less we're still keeping us on a
short leash
you boys know what took out our birds no
clue but there are definitely hostels
out there tiny with some troops out
there we're calling themselves wolves
you know we're dealing with now you're
dealing with me you're the one in charge
here who's asking McCall signs nomad I'm
the officer in charge of this operation
my operation is being massively wild
screw up hey old man you playing nice
I'm just trying to find out why a bunch
of grunts are falling from the sky into
our labs honey
well someone sank a naval cargo ship off
the coast then the entire archipelago of
a room went dark now we were sent here
to figure out what happened next thing
we know our choppers were taken down
that scar almost half of my soldiers are
dead best we can tell some kind of
military takeover Sentinel military
contractors they put this place under
martial law he's in the old boot in the
neck technique to enforce it this Cal
Tech is still making all the high-tech
stuff they always make is that maybe now
they're making more weapons not exactly
the libertarian utopia JCL advertised
where can I find juice go uh they had a
skel tech himself we haven't seen him
but his drones are keeping an eye on his
islands so you think he's still a part
of this I'm just not sure why all right
well but figuring it out on my to-do
list for now because he are wounded yeah
take me to my people one of your guys
nice dress but he won't shut up coming
down yeah mm-hmm and then come find me
I'll give you the guided tour all right
making friends at camp kind of the hard
way yeah kinda not the warm and fuzzy
welcome you nobody knows okay it's okay
it's rough out here rest
you guys oh yeah oh man that's awesome
you must go in here to do coops there
you go is nice I really like how they've
been incorporating like stories up and
then like general game stuff like kind
of seamlessly you know it means yeah I
just kind of bleeds into multiplayer and
singleplayer even like from the
character creation screen to here and
they've done a pretty good job
alright let's top here we go I gotta
calm you down
yeah hold
hey sorry man
nomads
who's left who made it hey you just
relax pal I'm doing what I can
you damn superhero
here here's another superpower I can't
find - but Weaver
you just relax about we'll take care of
it alright and the wasp yeah I'm with
the comms blackout I can't reach the
ship but I'll talk to man chills the big
guy he might have a boat I can use don't
you worry I'll come back with some help
go yikes that guy he was part of our
squad completed I see an objective over
there new exotic extract this game comes
out Friday we got a code to play a
little early
thanks for joining us no no but I know
there was new exclamation points ah see
we unlocked in we didn't even use it
yeah objective fourths
oh snap cool gotta get this fool there's
a little bio Oh see I was supposed to
fight them but it's a recommended level
150 yeah you try your throw away from
taking those guys out it's gonna be a 24
hour stream yo psych wow yeah good to
know good to know
wait what happened to my equipped
mission oh i unequipped it by doing I
see
all right yeah okay okay let's go yup
heat sounds good
mm-hmm yeah like just give me the
missions all right
PvP goes to war over there as you guys
can see yeah are you gonna stick to
single-player yeah I'm just gonna do
single-player today for sure for sure
I'm not sure what the guys are playing
on community Friday but since this game
officially releases on Friday maybe
they'll try the PD yeah with you guys my
objective looks like everybody else here
is also talking in their gang gang get
in line you're like excuse me
how's your pal
hold it up thanks for looking after him
you heard anything about a lieutenant
colonel Walker hmm not the guy the worst
what the troops call themselves the
wolves
you should be skelet ex-military advisor
heard he was an operator you know yeah
yeah we met a couple times
who is this might be a flashback mission
I don't know if or nothing
yeah cuz if you guys remember from
wildlands he was a good guy
he was on our side right pain look in
your eye you got big plans know how I
can get off this island
alright I'll leave us regular folk to
fend for ourselves huh how can he just
Matt we're here yeah
Oakland is 2,000 kilometers away it's an
awful long way to run with your tail
between your legs
I'm not running maths the USS Wasp is a
couple dozen clicks off the coast if I
can get there I can come back here with
some help the wasp ah not sure I'm fond
of the idea of a bunch of squids running
around our island hmm there are a couple
of jarheads on board too well if that's
the case
look I'll be straight with you we know
that we're no match for former spec ops
so some of our friends homesteaders and
Skell employees both believe in a line
on a couple of boats can you get them
protection on the wasp absolutely all
right I'll tell you where the boats are
to the boats to the boats all right
sounds good let's leave this please
let's ditch this popsicle stand oh yeah
there's a lot going on here yeah but I'm
kinda curious the job
[Music]
hi samam oh whoa oh my god art shop
interesting one level higher than the
guns I have I know how much money you
got oh I think I'm enough for this one
there is more tough recoil longer yeah
[Music]
the Scorpion no wait and oh how about we
get ourselves a helmet just kidding
elements in here let's be stuff you've
already picked up ah crafting we did run
over something earlier yeah okay okay
I kind of still want to get this song oh
I think these are all higher should we
save our money I don't have a good
loadout at the moment
oh yeah see these are all see because if
we're gonna take down oh homeboys with
the hundred fifty gears going after we
have the loader I got whatever you're
looking for all right sighs I'm really
gonna buy the TV says better ends look
like they're falling they do look like
they're sagging below the utility belt
it's really only have enough for like
two more guns and if I get this I only
have an upper one where I think I don't
know yeah so I'm gonna get this one
and then I can get one more I think
Rudy mi
[Music]
[Laughter]
I don't know let's get this one must be
we didn't get the sniper class right so
play to our strengths here yeah we want
the Scorpion nice the quit yeah whoo are
you score is rising you guys okay
alright alright now let's get out of
here so we can go to the boats
there is the end
Glenn says by the wolf mask I know I
missed it I'm actually is that anything
I need some protection from my face
here we go back into the wild y'all
this guy's outfits a teacher very cash
but like that one has like a design okay
super secret yeah
well ho
okay I did got some options oh you know
I'm not opposed to guided mode at the
moment sure
damn you are spring and I'll fight now
we can drive this helicopter yeah got
some vehicles here all right we out Wow
here we go not keeping quiet but yellow
they can't tell who's in here when I'm
in the sky oh and I can jump out of my
parish yeah you bought them are you uh
you upgraded to the parachute Wow
alright so we're going to the boats oh
my goodness if I didn't take the chopper
I think that would have been
feel like I'm paying up to where no
one's gonna like
Rajani that's much worse yeah
you're climbing Oh 1,100
I thought I was gonna say you're to
drive super in there got some XP Joel
says me and a friend are interested in
playing when I've heard there are a lot
of problems possibly during the beta we
heard chat talking about that earlier we
today we're playing the full version of
the game and it's going okay so far no
multiplayer or we haven't tried that yet
but so I can't speak to that single
players going just fine though there's a
lot to learn I mean that's the thing
about betas right you always have to
kind of take it with a grain of salt
because things can change or they use
that to see you know what is wrong that
they don't know about yet and stuff they
can't find out until it's in the hands
of players and live so yeah I did hear a
lot of things about the beta but I'm
helping save address those by now ooh I
see some red dot yeah three
[Music]
being close to the alternative are the
mission point here objective
we oh are you gonna yeah I was gonna say
you can't jump out and just parachute it
but I think you'd be really wise you
crazy no one else was in there I know
where did it go
I was like that was really fast oh yeah
water chopper go oh I don't have a
canteen rats where did it go yeah the
helicopter just yeah it just doesn't
exist anymore yeah it's over there
somewhere
that was fun though okay well it's a big
ass yeah Big Bird high every datum point
[Music]
Phoebe says Sam Fisher needs to return
that'd be cool I'd be a great cameo yeah
all right be helicoptered us whoa okay
I'm just here to talk yeah I'm not gonna
hurt anyone
Matt Schulze sent me you don't look like
homesteaders well I worked I work for
scale tech Mads is a friend when
Sentinel started arresting people he
helped us out why did he send you my
chopper got to this island from a Navy
ship just a few dozen clicks off this
coast I can get these boats back to that
ship and I can come back here with hope
Wow certainly sounds better than taking
a boat all the way to Auckland what
happened to your chopper Maurice Fox
this is my daughter harmony nice to meet
you call me nomad yeah we met another
soldier said his name was um Hill Josiah
Hill is he here no he helped us get
around some of sentinels men but he was
injured why not not them not badly and
we left him at this fishing building
area thing I actually think I know what
you're talking about
I'll pick him up after I get back Oh
yeah I've been waiting for the invasion
because I'm like was too peaceful we
flew here too easily
yeah no more bad guys everyone take
cover
all right hold up to play your draw game
we can do some recon yeah there they are
oh why did prompt you to take out your
drug working out of nowhere I don't
think they baited me into pulling out
the journals anything they're already
destroying yeah no no we see them thank
you very much pull your drone so cool
all right so uh rest in peace right
we lost one hold the right trigger to
move quicker
interesting Oh interesting okay yeah
yeah oh I was like oh that makes sense
right trigger without ABS engrain that
make sense
Macy Oh hip firing I definitely didn't I
was sure
all right so I'm not whipping out the
drone this time I'm not gonna hurt
anyone that Schultz sent me no well I
work for scale tech you hold that down
friend
oh and Sentinel start telling people he
helped us out 37 minutes top my chopper
got to this island from there we go oh
they really wanted me to hold down that
one for harmony what what are some cover
you got this person you know what to do
Oh out of my face I think I need to get
out of this area actually
well sorry innocent people you're
probably gonna get smoked but uh wait
was I not supposed to be seen I think
you're vain that's okay I was like all
right I'm girl they rushed you hard yeah
all right it's fine fine I was late F's
in the chat and we're good
you know when they're like this a
tactical shooter I'm like REM be
tactical I'm gonna hide behind a bit
wrong wait not that tactical for it's no
biggie
all right we're saying on the dock
that's just it right don't let them get
to the the good guys never risk our
lives why am i running like this there
we go there we go
in a rush to see these guys all right
I'm not gonna hurt anyone
Matt Schulze sent me you don't look like
home yeah we do well I work need a
launcher Oh that'll be cool Joe Jodi yes
more bad okay everyone take cover take
cover what this pool just don't man yeah
didn't you say you take every he's like
bring his hands up like I'm training
like I just sound like he was relaxing
he was great pressure you got this
more of them oh I see like an arrow off
in the back on the way but it's all good
oh yeah okay well you saved who you
needed the same Oh cuz more on the way
okay well just ignore the baddies birth
sec what the hell was that give me a
minute my god those people must be up a
new security program holy flying cow
I'm start saying that my guess is my
guess is nothing can come to or leave
this island as long as it's on hey that
must be what brought down my chopper
girl you jumped out of your tongue go
home me too kiddo listen you have to get
these people and you have to get out of
here what no one is coming to save you
and there's no ambulance on the way you
have to run you have to get to air one
okay yes
are you coming with us I'm gonna find my
friend he'll that fishing village left
him out was a fallback point there may
be other soldiers good luck
ooh all right
oh we saved him great job yeah I still
have this undisclosed yellow arrow
heading towards us
right in the privates I think so he's
just weird
at least he waited till we finished our
conversation yeah
I kind of wish I didn't destroy my
chopper now
all right back to base all right Jason
oh yeah
Oh a skill point all right I think we're
trying to save some possibly you know a
stoner what was that a gun
what's that yes our LMG damage two
drones up by four percent moose oh yeah
I got another early bracing job all
right
I only have one skill points I don't
know if I should save it's like it like
- oh this only takes one nice okay so
sixth sense mark all enemies in range
that's very good a remote killer
oh nice okay so I have to get access to
my sink shot kind of like in wild lands
for sure I like this one zone does this
and then I did have one of these but on
yeah level ten gears we level it up oh
wait uh oh okay
rats it's fine I'll use this one we're
gonna unlock that one next next time
and here I was on TV missions it can't
be that one yet I think this is already
going is it wait hold up
guitar Meister asks what is the guy
doing here
I'm hanging out y'all yeah oh yeah okay
cool hmm thanks for tuning in by the way
whoa here we go
now this one's like prettiest yeah this
is the right choice
I'm a girlie
suspicious noise okay so they gonna hear
you I am so in enemy territory and I
should try you got it holy whoa man
alright so next time I want to just
straight-up drive into enemy territory
it won't be this place literally the
heads like a nice looking headquarters
[Applause]
yeah there you go
walking out this whole camp
[Music]
Scott says I'm sick with the flu
watching your videos and they appreciate
you thank you for being here I'm so
sorry you're sick they keep coming you
keep laying them out oh there you go I
said vanish on the side there got to get
to that rock right now cover there we go
boys okay move you may see me I think
there's yeah the music is still like
yeah yeah got some discs yeah yeah
nothing now Wow Lazarus says you
vanished like Batman right yeah I
actually really glad you guys chose to
go with that one
Oh Sebastian ass so this may be both you
know whatever you're into destiny is
going through a lot of good changes
right now and this brand new I mean
which every whichever path you want to
go you know use your preference okay
yeah we did things this guy's still
looking for me huh look at him oh he's
running kind of bad whoa oh he's he's
going where you need to be no no he's
ready that's good I'm like I just want
to see how far he's really gonna go this
guy is sonic trying to come to you oh
wait oh I was still alive though
Christopher Christopher watching all the
way from Australia you're in the heat of
it right now friend thank you for
joining whoa I didn't think they would
still chase me this game is wild I think
you're right though they're like calling
me you know you're like no working
behind that rock and she definitely
thinks she losses vanish I've vanished
yes we want them to come oh I have no
Joel he is yeah this is people are
calling this a lightweight lunar shooter
because the volute and the colored loot
and the tiers of loot ammo I'm over here
being all wild meanwhile I'm almost yeah
oh man I should've leave it I wanted to
loot those bodies but are you completely
oh one bullet ooh spicy basically yeah
I'm watching all the way from Ontario
hey thank you for joining us who's that
Tony got Oh
nothing to see here
dudu I think at one point six kilometers
until I reach my objective cool more
viewers from that Toronto hey thank you
all for joining us whoa hmm
gee homey we are in the San Francisco
office we're here in California yeah you
got a loo a little bit huh Scott thank
you he's subscribed and yeah this is do
you like this game oh you know it's cool
so far yeah I feel like we're still
barely scratching the surface of this
game so that's always hard to like make
decisions like that yeah there's a lot
to learn but and if we didn't get the
hands-on the beta so we're learning
right here but it's going well there is
a lot to learn a massive skill tree I
think I like it so far because it is
actually a challenge it's good like the
fact that they still kept pursuing me
even after I thought I was in the clear
yeah that's fine yeah it's a little
better most games don't do that and you
you know get used to getting away with
like total BS and your games all the
time
Cmdr Elric sup hey welcome thank you for
joining us okay greetings from holland
hey alright thank you guys thank you all
for joining
is this a closed beta or the actual game
it's the actual game we got the code
early and so we had the opportunity to
play
I'm Maris oh hi can I take them out with
my last 62 bullets we can't make that
choice for you they'll ring about
pre-ordering but we're having a good
time if you like these like these Tom
Clancy game this might be another good
one to pick up
hopefully our stream gear can guide you
in that direction but we're having fun
overall all right nice I've destroyed
these guys and I've taken all their ammo
and i leveled up campers great job skill
point there's a little red zone here
right here stuff oh it's a chopper y'all
there 30 room no yep get out of here you
Pro in camo yeah thanks I kind of like
that it does take a little while to get
it going but it's worth it okay yep
gathering almost like us to smoke this
guy and then gather himself let's do it
face I believe in the end zone Chris
keeps bringing that up I mean I don't
know if you're interested further by
putting the weapon on semi-auto and then
holding the trigger you'll uh you'll run
faster Oh appreciate the tip please
we're gonna may not need it at the
moment
the baz greetings from the swiss army
base rock oh thank you whoa whoa whoa
whoa thank you for joining us
whoa out of my sheer like panic I have
some victory
the camera and you know what a bacon
memories you know you know Here I am
about tripping look at the dodge on that
I totally dodged his gunfire there this
is like smash brothers last week it was
in the wrong place at the wrong time
I just wanted to interrogate him Johnny
pay yeah photo mode that was pretty
funny i panning the freeze-frame here's
the moment I knew one button plus one
pineapple all right take a look at the
cosmetics store Stefan says play the
open beta had a bunch of bugs got the
pre-ordered I got the game pre-ordered
hope most of it is fixed yeah we had has
been saying that the people who have
played the beta it was a little buggy we
haven't gotten into multiplayer but the
single campaign mode is going well so
far no not really I didn't notice any
bugs or anything yeah I mean I'm seeing
a few little like I don't know weird
like lines through the middle and the
graphics a little bit but I don't know
if all the settings are where they
should right might not be completely
optimized we got the code and we just
jumped on straight for sure but excited
that's okay it's I'm sure it's something
that can be adjusted is some minor
screen tearing
all right so I got some new good Mitch
thanks your new DMR I'm liking this for
sure Sebastian asks are you getting
Destiny's early mm-hmm
as far as I know no but tomorrow we
definitely it might be playing out with
David yeah David's is the destiny man
yeah well there's a few in the office
he's a super fan love David
Citizen Kane no the game is out on
Friday we got a code early so we're
playing it early for y'all thank you for
oh yeah there was a music you I just
don't like that yeah
freaked out oh you know I'll read the
specs of this pc we're playing on I got
asked Erik Tay cuz that is a good
question for I don't know off the top of
my head you know any of the specs I'm
not sure that's okay yeah I don't want
to misspeak so next time I'll find out D
Creed can I have a code sorry friend we
got this one I know yeah we asked the
same question around the office
sometimes I really want to get him and
they're like no code for me oh my god no
yeah it's even hard to get one around
here Eric Tay is a destiny man you know
what we will admittedly say he fell off
because of early destiny too but you
know I'm sure we can get him in here
sneak them in sometimes he's a busy man
nowadays but yeah you might open field
dropped decreed what do you guys think
of the game so far we're having some fun
we uh I don't come from a like a Tom
Clancy background in general but this
game is like it's going pretty well so
far
it's it makes you kind of calm down and
be a lot more tactical although we are
kind of running guns a-blazing that's I
think that's both of our place
hey general though I think we're having
a lot of fun yeah I kind of like the
little mechanics like camo prone like
you really get you got to think you know
I'm used to all these FPS is where you
don't think and shoot first yeah I was
definitely about to run in and like
shoot this whole group of people than
these two why would you even need a park
this guy's like well the cars are gone
so that's a good thing so does the
in-game store work yet or our loot boxes
a post-launch thing the in-game store in
single-player mode is there
we haven't jumped in a multiplayer mode
if that's where you're referring to no
loot boxes that we haven't seen yet
we're playing single-player
I think I'll spare these guys life I
gotta go find Josiah once I find Josiah
that's probably gonna wrap up this dream
so that's why I'm gonna try to just get
there oh for sure it's already 1:30 yeah
I know invite so pass
yeah appreciate you guys sticking around
we had a late start to the stream
because we got the code a little late
but yeah we really wanted to get the
game on to the stream today and that
involved that never gets all this close
I've literally in the bath holy moly
I probably could have picked a a
slightly okay okay
they're moving okay see I'm so
camouflaged that they didn't even want
to take my path they're like can't even
see this path any nope
you're just part of the ground what
difficulty are we on person this is
normal it'll be easy but that's how I
generally play too I felt like
oh there's chit-chatting all right NATO
says no kill them all no we spared their
life essence now that I almost ran out
of bullets
oh no who's seen you the car behind you
might have known somewhere
hello from the Carolinas what up Brandon
thanks for joining
we're ought to wrap in a little bit yeah
yeah it's gone Wow wait says why to
focus oh there it is there to service
hmm whew okay
you know I swim over the I know I'm like
there better be a bowl
yeah how's the stealth swim that's an
option as I would say oh yeah B's delt
swim just in case you know we have to
take a refreshing dish after covering
ourselves in mud multiple times rolling
around mud
oh nice okay I was like sweet yeah yeah
we flew the helicopter earlier and then
we jumped out of it and activator our
parachute it was actually pretty fun it
was pretty great we jumped right into a
cutscene version pitch the helicopter
and he launched her parachute Oh
Daniel thank you he says yo GameSpot
Ghost Recon fan here love you guys
also sending love from Poland thank you
thank you for joining us all right boo
okay yeah maybe one more little hey Red
Queen no a selfie white rabbit no matter
Josiah
holy [ __ ]
nice to see you're still above-ground
anyone else from your Chuck whew
but we're scattered man we sure screwed
the pooch on this one another thing it's
so silly what so funny
I added some tats had to choose I am i
saw Walker out there hunting down our
soldiers you saw who
Lieutenant Colonel Walker Colt Walker
here fighting our guys there's no way oh
I guess you sorry saw what we saw man
believe it Walker is a traitor it's what
I saw or the that bastard's gonna pay
mm-hmm
you know it's tough because like you
know knowing what we know from wildlands
it's like I know some schedule that was
going on so I'm just gonna pick that's
what I saw I can't believe it he's one
guy I admired you know guess you're
wrong
ding I know right lots of breathing yeah
Bob Jones says so many debates cars yeah
Lots we added our own we got the Joker
one so what's your lay of the land
oh we got a homie now oh snap
[Music]
either Walker's thank that cargo ship or
someone he was working with did look
who's that got a cellphone now yeah yes
Walker is that Punisher guy the guy who
played The Punisher I always forget his
real name who sank the military ship man
we got hella Intel here's the clues
you've collected click here to resolve
them sticky Oh Oh interesting okay okay
Sebastian you know I don't think we have
a least favorite part of the game so far
unless but we kind of just started yeah
nothing yet it's going good
Jace Kell sunk that cargo ship damn
everything that happens here is cuz of
that prick
I'll locate juice girl I met some Skell
ticket I'll see what they know how did
you thinking about to all the ones I
smoked I'm like no survivors well link
up at RP Delta
sounds good yeah dude I actually like
wanna keep playing but we got I felt
like it barely did anything we got a lot
like we jumped there's a lot to learn
and we all kind of just learned here
during the stream but now when it's
getting like you know now that things
are going a little smoother of course
it's stream' times over post it up for
the Grammys for the gram Kimberly hi oh
thank you for joining all right let's
take a photo before we do this boom all
right for the Graham time of Dane Jack
15 says gets tattoos and becomes a
manager at Hot Topic everyone had all
these tattoos we were tatted up scarred
up mm-hmm Wow there's
yeah wow you can really edit oh man
we're really getting somewhere now I
know this is awesome
Sebastian says those tattoos are fire
though yeah Persia pick them out
ourselves a pretty dope no how do I take
the photo it looks so rule hmm this is
something I would definitely like is it
a right bumper like to get to the
shutter no we just want to take a
picture
I know screenshot than f12 oh it's
bright that's for like the computer I
still want it I'm just gonna get the
perfect angle here love it there boom
okay you guys we are officially done
with the stream today I had a ton of fun
playing the game a little bit early but
for everybody else I believe if you are
part of you play and you get a certain
addition mmm I know sorry this
information is bad but you can play
early but world right world wide release
is gonna be this Friday so if you like
what you saw and you want to see more
then get on that ASAP this week is
actually stacked there are so many
amazing things going on yeah
apex legend season three's common
destiny shadow key that's on the way too
so a lot of really cool things coming up
this week and if you guys are new to
GameSpot live we are here every weekday
at 11 a.m. so please fellow for you to
come back next time we were a little
late today but that's because we got
access to this awesome unit first
but 11:00 a.m. PST that is where we are
most the time thank you guys so much for
tuning in and we will see you tomorrow
bye bye